hello freak [ __ ] I am so high-strung
and I do like you know feel like I'm
prone to like I can't be walking around
telling dads at my school to [ __ ] off
you know do that I told one get it go
find go you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what happened he's just a he's a
[ __ ] dick to my son the dad was the
dad was he was a basketball coach
and I saw him I go hey real [ __ ] you
know that
whoa and mm-hmm because no dad's talk to
each other like that and I yeah I call
this guy's an [ __ ]
and I felt bad again I feel [ __ ] bad
I don't want to do it but I did it and
he's a dick and everybody knows he's a
[ __ ] dick and boy is your coach name
is coach out of school yeah is he still
there any or is he done that he's done
yeah well there's a lot of people that
can't mean the stress of being a comic
right as one crash trust imagine a
stress of dealing with hormonal II
active 17 year olds every [ __ ] year
new ones coming in just chaos younger
this is 14 there's no not even that
being an [ __ ] to an 11 year old oh
well he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
wow there's a lot of [ __ ] stress and
raising people and teaching kids and
dealing with the problems that kids
present you know yeah a lot of people
that just here's another thing that's
going on today people think they can
have a kid and then have careers to and
everyone's happens a career the mom is a
career the dad as a career everybody has
a career and what did you think when you
when you watching the kid who's paying
attention to the kid I went to a party
and I've talked about this in the
podcast before this one little kid was
just running around hitting everybody
and doing the parents are inside
drinking they were in the party drinking
and the kids out there with the other
kids
and then finally the guy comes out an
apology I'm sorry he's a good kid it's
not good kid like he's hit three kids
yeah yeah I told him what the kid did he
goes he never did that I go I saw him do
that watch your son beena and the guys
like I said I'm sorry I'm like oh my god
I want to kill you yeah like do you
understand I want to grab your neck and
choke the life out of you I'm containing
myself yeah [ __ ] Khan yes I get in
the pin noses yeah I would I keep it
cool I keep it going
how do you do it I don't know because I
practice murder on a daily basis oh my
god I just murdered a punching bag or I
run out pills I get it out of my system
Bert just told me this story about you
exercising such calm you and Tate and
that guy with his shirt off that was
trying to get into your hotel room oh
yeah you know and I would have [ __ ] I
don't know what I would have done I'm
not gonna you know that's the other
thing it's like I would just put that
guy walking unconscious yeah they put
him to sleep
choked him unconscious but Tate was nice
to him he could have taken his life that
guy was a real piece of [ __ ] he was a
big giant dude he was like six foot six
and he was a bully and he thought you
know because he was so tall he thought
that people were scared of him but you
know he [ __ ] with the wrong guy in
Tate first of all a guy who's been
arrested been around bad people his
whole life been in numerous street
fights was a professional fighter was on
The Ultimate Fighter was a black belt in
jujitsu I mean everything was wrong and
and Tate was trying to be calm with the
guy and the way Tate handled it like he
they fought in a hotel lobby right in
front of the elevator and the guy was
pounding on his door saying you're in my
[ __ ] room I think I was at just a
[ __ ] and Tate was like nah look Mike he
works here it's definitely my room and
he shuts the door on where he was he
[ __ ] [ __ ] you think you can get
away with shutting this [ __ ] door he
was open this [ __ ] door I told you in
my room and then we all went outside it
was me and Eddie Bravo and Tate we're
looking at this guy and we're looking at
his friend and we're trying to figure
out how we're gonna do this like this
this has to be dealt with like this is
not a guy that's gonna go away he was a
big drunk dumb guy and Tate decides the
way to handle it is you know there's a
bunch of words being exchanged so Tate
decides he he kicks the guy in a leg in
the leg and then he grabs him and pulls
him on top of him so the guy like
literally has no idea like why so he
does he kicks his leg grabs him and
pulls him on top of him and pulls him
into what's called the guard
in jiu-jitsu and then wraps him up in
something called an omoplata which is a
shoulder lock so he throws I mean this
is all instantaneous kick pull clap
throws his shoulder over them then the
security guard show up the security
guards show up and they go hey hey hey
what the [ __ ] is going on and I go relax
I go everything's gonna be fine he's
just gonna choke him to sleep and
they've got the security guard goes joe
rogan are you Joe Rogan holy [ __ ] man
what are you doing here while I said
this like he's just gonna choke him
sleep tape goes all right I guess I'm
gonna choke him asleep now hey I mean
this is all happening within seconds
Tait sinks a rear-naked choke on this
guy and just squeezes him unconscious
gets off of him
doesn't hurt the guy at all doesn't hit
him all he does kick his leg out from
under him take him down
choke him unconscious the guy his friend
picks his friend up I and I go get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] friend and get sober him up
and get him out of here and he's lucky
nothing happened and he's like I'm sorry
man my friend's piece of [ __ ] I'm sorry
his friend picks his friend up the guys
like delirious they pushed him in an
elevator elevator door closes he
disappears from life never see him again
that's it the end of it I take pictures
with the [ __ ] security guards their
smile and I go is fine I go he's a drunk
[ __ ] do you think we should call the
cop let go no that guy's humiliated I
can unless he comes back if he comes
back he's gonna get [ __ ] up but right
now everything's fine don't call the
cops yeah so they're laughing and
everyone's laugh we took a couple
pictures together went back in the room
what got some dinner and we were
laughing yeah but when that dad is in
your face at the party that exercise
that calm is that's again that's the
thing that I struggle with when Mike
Kosta is on stage and I'm being
completely honest like I don't again
this is how I feel and it's just
something that takes over and I'm like I
can't help but say hey your son is
hitting that guy this is not cool this
is not okay yeah
parents don't watch their kids and then
their kids are just complete [ __ ]
well they go to parties and they drink
and they leave the kids outside and this
parents these particular parents they
don't watch the kid ever
they this is like what they're famous
for apparently in their group they just
don't watch this kid
they just they don't want to be parents
they became parents in their 40s they
didn't really plan it out
I don't know if the parents get along I
don't know I don't know how but the
whole thing looks like a disaster and
the kids a little monster and they just
are not they're not disciplining and
paying attention and like he literally
went out talked to the kid in there was
some commotion going on where people
complaining about the kid hitting
somebody he talked to the kid and then
he high-fived them and then the kid went
back to doing it again I mean literally
he went back inside to drink the kid
went back outside again so at the end of
the night when this guy apologized to me
like it the kid was doing it all night I
go hey man your kid is really aggressive
he's like I'm sorry I'm sorry about the
kid I go your kid is really aggressive
is no he's a good kid I go no look he
hit three people I saw him hit people
I saw him push a kid and call him a
loser I go he's [ __ ] six and he's
doing this he goes that never happened
I'm like you know I'd understand
consequences this is why I bite my
tongue I understand like the the actual
consequences of smacking this guy in his
[ __ ] mouth which is what I wanted to
do you know of course I want if there
was no consequences to doing anything
and I didn't think of him as a person I
didn't think of him as a guy who just
never raised a kid before hasn't really
thought about it well has a big career
probably busy all the time
wife's busy all the time just not doing
a good job raising a little monster you
know
Lincoln to try to drown out the fact who
knows why you know drinking because he
doesn't like being married drinking
because he doesn't like being a dad
drinking cuz he doesn't like being sober
who knows I don't know I don't know the
guy but in that moment when he's looking
at me and going that never happened I
just did just a [ __ ] sheer ignorance
and incompetence and irresponsibility
was just so infuriating because I
watched my kids like I like I watched
him I talked to him I communicated with
him I know I didn't have a good
childhood so for me it's important to be
a good dad and to spend as much time as
I can communication
explaining [ __ ] talk to him treating
them like I'm not just their dad but
also I'm their friend and I care about
them my wife is a first grade teacher
and she's becoming an educational
therapist right now and so I'm like
living with just the master had
consequences like if you don't eat in
our house or decide you don't like
broccoli nothing else is coming like
kitchen is closed and that's what people
create monsters when they cater to him
so much that's okay
let me and that's we like your kid only
eats [ __ ] rice I have a friend who
and he keeps feeding this [ __ ] kid
sugar this kid just eats nothing but
sugar all day because he doesn't need he
doesn't need what do mean he doesn't
need he's always eating cookies is
because he won't eat his food
I gotta feed him something I go no dude
you gotta tell him you can't eat the
cookies you got food
you got actual food this [ __ ] kid is
just eating nothing but candy I mean
it's it's bananas he's always gonna soda
in his hand oh good he's six
he's [ __ ] six and he's drinking a
full coke like you go over the house the
kid has a root beer we saw these kids we
were on a flight and saw these two
parents sit in first class and then come
back and check we didn't know we'll put
a kid in coach they put three next to
each other in coach small the [ __ ] I
know crazy right and then everybody else
has to do with their kid they gave each
of them iPads right and then they
waitress a waitress the house stewardess
comes by and she looks at these three
kids and looks around for who they're
with and one day all the kids I'm
telling eight is the oldest one eight
maybe six and four three just in a row
Jesus and [ __ ] all this one goes three
sprites three sprites this is a red eye
this is an overnight flight they're on
iPads like just animals just don't stop
like trying to win something you know
and then we're sort of laughing at first
but everybody in our family wants to go
sleep there is like exhausted from being
out all day I've never would there's a
while ago I'll never be on this flight
again no red eyes for me this horrible
horrible really [ __ ] you up for days two
days afterwards you're [ __ ] yeah try
to do anything in your power to avoid a
red eye also try to do everything in
your power to avoid looking and if you
can fly non-stop that's whatever sighs
yep
yeah so they get in a fight after a
while oh good start fighting cuz they're
all hopped up on sugar and a monster
screen and [ __ ] so then they start
fighting and I think the mom or dad
hears or somebody has to tap them to get
up and me and my wife like this is not
okay just not nothing was said because
again we just want to mind our own
business ideally right again ideally
everyone Minds their own business this
is a new world though this world of
electronic babysitters in the world of
putting the kids and coach and you go in
the first class like ignoring kids and
it's these career people there's a lot
of people that look they their career
requires all their time they justify by
go look someone's got to make the money
in this household so we keep up this
lifestyle and so they're out there
[ __ ] grinding all yeah and then the
kids are just what do I do was raising
me full circle to my dad passing away is
that every single weekend this is why I
bought that FJ 62 Land Cruiser because
every single weekend we went on a little
family trip and I looked at myself and
we go on family vacations and stuff but
the amount of time that my family really
spent together like a mom and a dad like
he would take us to Yosemite he would
take us up the coast to Mendocino we'd
go to Marin or Stinson Beach you're in
all these places even in Golden Gate
Park like he would just take us places
little adventures you know and so I feel
like we need to I get caught up and work
working because you know just non-stop
and I gotta take a step back and really
spend as much time as I possibly can
[Applause]
[Music]